in today's disgusting but totally unsurprising
news.
Donald Trump allegedly referred to MSNBC reporter
Katie tour's transgender, your mom
as a bitch with a tranny dad.
Those are the president's alleged words, so
I'm allowed to say them.
This is from a new book called sinking in
the swamp by Lackland marquee and to ask,
so when sub sang, Katie tour is the daughter
of Zoe tour.
You might remember Zoe tour from the OJ Simpson
low speed helicopter car chase in that white
Bronco in 1994 if you were around then, Zoe
tour doesn't like Trump and Zoe tour is a
trans woman and the book alleges that Donald
Trump makes horrible comments about women
all the time.
He called a Megan McCain, the daughter of
the late Senator John McCain, dumber than
her father pointed out that she's been getting
a fatter after she said things on the view
that Trump didn't like.
This actually started with Trump getting into
it with Katie tour herself when he was running
for president, writing off requestion.
Sometimes during interviews when he didn't
want to answer one of her questions, he would
say, Oh, give me a break.
Next question.
Katie.
Very, very condescending.
He started calling her little Katie, started
calling her a third rate journalist, all of
that stuff, and once when she tried to follow
up a question with Trump, he simply said,
be quiet.
Then of course we get to these latest allegations
that Trump referred to Katie Toor privately
as again a bitch with a tranny dad referring
to Katie tour's transgender mom.
This is the president now he will have defenders
no matter what he says, and lots of people
probably agree with him.
There's a lot of people in this country, I
don't know if it's, you know, 15% 17% that
are extremely anti-trans and while they probably
would never be willing to say what Donald
Trump is accused of saying, they aren't going
to get too upset about hearing that Donald
Trump said it.
That's one group.
There's also people who don't necessarily
even agree with Trump attacking trans people,
but they do generally want things to sort
of go back to the way they imagined things
were in the 1950s and they see treating trans
people respectfully as something that's not
quite in line with their 1950s ideal.
So they're not really going to get bent out
of shape about attacking trans, but they're
not going to go and do it themselves.
And then of course, remember first lady, Melania
Trump's big initiative was going to be ending
bullying, fighting bullying, and her husband
is one of the biggest bullies of all sorts
of different groups of people based on their
identity that we know of.
I wish it weren't the case, but too many people
either like comments like these or they're
just indifferent.
As long as Trump won't let Mexicans in the
country, right, or whatever their priority
is.
It's one of those areas where we just need
to change the dialogue completely.
A different president could do that.
We talk about lots of the things that would
take a long time to change, and Trump didn't
create racism.
Trump didn't create xenophobia or anti-trans
bias or antisemitism.
But when he says things like this, when he
doesn't do anything about the coalescing and
growing, uh, extremist movements, he makes
the people who are into those ideologies emboldened
and more comfortable publicly displaying their
beliefs.
If Trump leaves the white house in a year,
um, that's not going to change the views of
these extremists, but it might put them back
at least in a little bit of a more hidden
position in society where they might think
twice about going public with these views.
And then over time, hopefully those views
will continue to dissipate or age out as we
like to say.
We can hope.
Imagine being Katie tour and finding out that
the president referred to a parent of yours
in this way, it's almost inconceivable, or
at least they've would've been in 2015 but
this is 2020 United States and this story
barely makes headlines in the midst of everything
else that's
going on.
Really, really shocking stuff.